what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax L this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sister Sophia and
Giggles ggle the clown E I don't want to
be a clown you didn't say you looked
great today so
thanks for letting people know that
Sophia I'm sorry I'm sorry okay wait I
want to kind of start out with this
first question because you thought this
one that I wrote down was a really weird
question to ask can I give some context
this is one of those episodes where we
actually have nothing prepared so I
don't know what she wrote down she
doesn't know what I wrote down and I
opened my computer right as we sat here
and the first thing says would you give
up your whole life if you got a letter
from Hogwarts debate okay so this is
this is why I asked so currently we're
in this this like Hogwarts Harry Potter
series binge right and so I thought I
said would you cinee if you got a letter
right now so you would be like a very
old high school student are you saying
I'm a super senior super super super
senior but you had to give up your
entire life like you can never see your
parents again your friends your animals
uh your boyfriend whoever it is you have
to go to Harry Potter like or not Harry
Potter you have to go to Hogwarts they
said okay you have would you give up
everything no question sayara family
I'll never see you again okay side
question what if it wasn't Hogwarts it
was one of the other schools like the
all girl school like your backup school
yeah your backup choice um still yes you
would Sophia you have one life on this
Earth and you have the option to be a
wizard with a wand and live in a
mythical land yeah yeah I would too I
would too by Mom no taxes uh that's 9 to
who said that they didn't have taxes
they don't show it in the movie so I'm
assuming they don't like no real world
responsibility about the classes that
you get to take like dark arts class you
know I mean it's incredible quit it you
get that's your that's your PE but you
start laughing last night because we're
talking about all the classes that we
could possibly take at Hogwarts now
we're really thinking this is a
possibility and then we said what if
they gave us our schedule back and it we
look at our schedule it says US history
no it's like dark arts quiddit training
all of the Hogwarts classes and then
it's like Spanish 101 damn it like wait
Eon biology Anatomy no I think that
would be so much fun okay fine I would I
you know what I'm going to start doing
instead of asking men what their zodiac
is on a date I'm going to say what house
are you in that definitely tells a lot
about someone's character I went out
with a guy and he told me Hufflepuff I
never called him back that's a I like
huffle puff not for that reason Robert
pson was a Hufflepuff and he was
definitely arguably the cutest one in
the show movie you think yeah who do you
think I don't know we're on we're on a
who wait who what are you I guarantee
she's gonna say snap no sick person are
you kidding me why did why did we have a
giant cutout Snape looks like he could
be my dad though like we do kind of have
some similar facial you guys do what if
that's the reason why you get called is
because Snape's your father and you are
a Slytherin it makes sense that's true
does make sense wait okay so just to
change subjects um please so I found out
that the rash I talked about oh my
God guys wait can I just talk can I vent
a little bit what are we talk about now
I'm going to vent so a couple episodes
ago probably the first episode I talked
about how I had like a rash all over my
neck and my
face apparently I have late onset eczema
so now I have eczema and now I have to
deal with this my eyes are burning my
neck is super itchy and I didn't realize
this is a thing cystic acne and eczema
at 27 years old you got I got EG you got
eczema you got egg I'm not going to lie
sopia yeah you're you haven't been on a
great journey with your skin so far no
my body's freaking out right now but
I'll tell you something I did that was
so stupid and I caught it yesterday what
just to make yourself feel a little
better a few episodes ago I was bragging
about how my skin is so good and I'm not
doing that much and that's my
secret turns
out do you have Asma no I don't have
Amma turns out the moisturizer that I
was putting on my face every day and
every
night is in
moisturizer what is this like a Mean
Girls thing it's foot cream it's leave
in
conditioner no I have been putting leave
how is your face off freaking out I
don't know maybe I have is that a hack
maybe but don't try this at home but if
you do try it let us know the result it
was an honest mistake because I got a
whole kit a conditioner a serum and a
moisturizer and they all look the same
all the same color the writing is really
small and I wasn't really thinking I was
just putting it on and it feels like a
moisturizer a hair company also makes
moisturizers
and but apparently not CU it's for your
hair I've been putting it on my face for
months it's probably just like it
probably said like leaveing moisturizing
I was wondering why I smelled like um
you know when like a dog just gets a
bath yeah smell like that all the time
canine that's oh God yeah no it's we're
definitely struggling and then I bought
all this stuff I got mad at s on the
walk today I go did you drink my
turmeric shot and she goes yes it helped
me throat you know what's so weird about
living with someone there's this whole
refrigerator debate of what you're
allowed to have what's Community Food
and what's just
yours you so bad at sharing that's
I what have I not shared with you cinee
your milk that's false you like oat milk
I like almond mil sometimes I take some
of yours and you're like first all I
never knew that you took my almond milk
that makes sense why I'm running out
fast I shouldn't have said that's really
thank you I'm going to go buy two today
no I just I just B all this stuff to fix
cuz I think I have like inflammation or
something in my body and my body's
freaking out and so I don't know how to
fix it so I'm eating all these
anti-inflammatories I'm drinking like
celery juice which is so gross in the
morning and turmeric and ginger and
cayenne I want to throw up sus s aoo do
you think you're really stressed and
that's why all these things are coming
out of your pores does it sound like I'm
stressed a little bit well this is the
problem this is what's what's so
annoying about stress cuz that
definitely isn't like an attribute to
everything that I'm feeling but I'm
pissed about is that when these things
come up you're even more stressed
because now you're stressed out that
your skin is stressed out so now it's
just like this horrible tunnel and then
all of a sudden everyone's like oh
meditate and relax my I look like a toad
and I'm peeling off my neck obviously s
said I was shedding the like two weeks
ago and I'm supposed to calm
down so I'm not
calm we can tell yeah so this is fun if
you have anything to recommend and help
go back to
therapy I'm going on Thursday
that's hot girls do therapy hot girls
have eczema and hot girls have IBS thank
you anyway we went to LA recently
because
Sophia gave an incredible speech and I'm
very proud of you thank you I did have
money if you were going to stumble and
you didn't so I did lose $10 yeah you
did it with our security guy that was
protecting us and he goes that's messed
up took sister took money took my money
oh that's funny um yeah so to what sinee
was talking about we went to LA because
I had had two open heartart surgeries
and one of them was at Children's
Hospital and so they came to me because
they wanted me to talk about my story
and share my experience and then also
share how I'm doing now which I hope
they don't listen to this because to
doing great amazing um but no so obv no
I am doing well so I come into this
thinking it's a small lunch and they say
it's a lunch so you think lunch's
probably what like 50 women at you know
I was assuming it would be six tables
eight people I thought it was just going
to be a couple women that are big donors
and I'm just supposed to like R Dazzle
them the thing is is that I have a
severe fear of public speaking severe
like I cannot stand like even in high
school and college there was nothing
more terrifying to me than standing up
in front of an audience but that shocks
me from you because is you have a
podcast and you're very comfortable
speaking on camera you have a TV show
every time you do an interview or you're
on live TV or you have a zoom thing
you're so eloquent and you know exactly
what to say and you nail it so that is
shocking to me that you'd be so nervous
there's a difference though when you're
when you're going up and presenting
something when it's a script like that
that freaks me out if if I had to do a
teleprompter like I actually whenever we
would do those interviews and there's a
teleprompter that I have to read off my
heart is racing like I'm I'm really
nervous and so it's kind of a problem
because I had to say this whole speech
is a page and a half of what I had to
say C knows I was losing I probably read
my speech 50 times we actually went to
the it ended up being a huge ballroom
with like 500 people yeah five yeah oh
that's the thing we walk in C's like oh
let's go check out the room so you can
practice it is 500 women 500 it's on me
doing a small speech now I realized I
walk in Mass M stage it's 500 women I
have to talk to yeah yes so I was losing
my [__] that night but you did such a
good job they played this video montage
of Sophia's almost heart Journey from
when she was a baby till now showing
photos of her when she was in the
hospital and like me and her walking
down the hallway right after surgery I
balled my fake lashes off she was crying
it was really
cute he's laughing something funny Chris
no that's an endearing story I was
actually tearing up oh you tearing up
yeah his lashes are falling off too I
don't know why I've heard this story a
million times every time someone talks
about it I just lose my mind because I
don't think you're obviously the one
getting the operation so you're dealing
with your own mental Warfare already but
it's so interesting how it affected each
one of our family members differently
and I remember I was in eighth grade and
I had just taken my final exam and I was
begging my teachers to take the exam
early so that I could go to the hospital
and be there right before you go into
surgery MH oh my God I have you know how
people remember like strange details
about a traumatic time mhm I remember I
was wearing fuzzy socks and Ugg boots
and three layers and I sweat through two
of them and I had nervous and I took my
so I had to throw my socks away I was
sweating like I was um well you're
obviously more of mess but it was so
weird seeing your older sister in that
environment you had a giant tube coming
out of your neck you looked like a ghost
oh I would hate to see like that yeah
yeah when I close my eyes and night I
still see
it yeah no so I will say thank the Lords
I actually did it really well like I
killed it I killed and I'm so proud of
myself because I practiced a lot that
definitely helped but you know what's so
underrated I know this sounds silly and
and everyone says this this is actually
taking three deep breaths I know I know
everyone's like oh you people always
truly taking those deep breaths like
three holding it and letting it go
because my heart was racing and I know
that when I have a fear of doing
something my heart races my hands shake
and then that's when I start to mumble
and I start to speed my speech and so
I'm like I need to calm my heart rate
and I think I can kind of get through
this and that's really what I did was
focus on getting my heart rate down and
then I was able to do it and then you
were so natural up there thanks you were
riffing with the audience you flowed
naturally I blocked out I had no idea if
I did blocked out she was hammered but
you did such a good job I'm so proud of
you thank you thank you we did have a
really interesting evening to follow
what did we do that evening we went
to our cousin's house oh gosh and you
are just a silly goofy fool what is
wrong with me and famous NFL players and
really messing up bad in front of them
more than one I almost killed on
Thanksgiving yeah you almost did kill
one on Thanksgiving I I now I oh so do
you want to explain
sure sure we're all sitting around the
dinner table and Sophia's standing for
some reason mhm my uncle says something
funny because I think it has something
to do with his pee cuz he keeps peeing
blue he's taking some medication and
it's making him like he says he's peeing
like a Smurf yeah so he keeps peeing
blue and as he was saying that in front
of this NFL athlete who isn't just an
NFL he happens to be like the the guy
the guy the big guy Sophia takes a huge
sip of water and I'm behind him he's
sitting in a chair like this and I'm
standing right here listening to the
story and she does a spit take all over
his back back and and to make it worse
to make it worse you run out of the room
grab your purse run past the table and
said we're leaving now goodbye and just
left you didn't even say I'm sorry you
didn't even grab a napkin for him you
just left the moment I saw him do this I
was like I'm out I'm out oh God it's so
embarrassed do that I didn't mean to of
course I like did I think I haven't done
a spit take who does spit takes anymore
no one no one I just drank water at the
worst moment and I spit it all over his
back and obviously I've realized this
about myself fight or flight I flight I
flew she flew I flew I ran out of there
producer Chris producer Chris told us
that's assault if you spit on someone
and leave
lock her up lock her up clink clink so I
assaulted an NFL player
accidentally but he also said I'll see
you in New York to sis I so I think I'm
forgiven she said intentionally she knew
what she was doing leaving an imprint
this what am I like marking my territory
like a dog maybe you were maybe
internally oh my God you actually have
had such a random last few days and then
what happened to you at the airport oh
wait you're this is so funny okay you're
so think that's so creepy yeah wow I've
been like on a level right now um so
basically stin and are in line at the
airport and I'm not looking too bad but
I'm I'm also just it's 700 in the
morning and we're waiting in line to
check into our flight and I see there's
a guy like one person ahead of us and
he's so cute he's super tall and he's
definitely my type looks like a golfer
kind he's like 65 he doesn't look like
golfer but he just had golfer guy he
looks like a basketball player
really well he was wearing basketball
gear he's wearing sweatpants well it
looked like one of those travel team
outfits whatever so he was wearing a
hoodie that said USC and pants that said
USC and I thought in my head fellow
Trojan like no fight on should I say
something I know Sophia's Brain before
she even asked to say anything she looks
at me I look at her and she just gives
me sisters have this where you just have
that look in your eye and I said okay
she thinks this guy is obviously very
attractive so I do say so creepy though
I didn't we're in line for I kid you not
2 minutes and she shows me your phone
and found his name his profile his
LinkedIn found everything in 90 seconds
where he worked and I said you the
creepiest person in my defense in my
defense his bag had his first and last
name on him he looked
at insane cuz I wanted to see how old he
was in case I was like going to hit on a
I knew what she was doing she goes
should I say something should I say
something I said no it is too early for
this it is too early I think in this is
the thing i' I've had this
newfound confidence in the mentality of
saying what if this is the one like what
if hear me out hear me out hear me out
you hear about those stories of like
missed opportunities and I should have
said yes I regret it blah blah blah and
so suddenly my mind just goes I just
have to say like just say High cuz what
if what if just what that's it what if
I'll tell you what the truth behind it
if we were on the street if we were
anywhere if we had a restaurant there
wouldn't have this wh if in your head
there's something about being at the
airport where if you see someone
remotely your age you romanticize a life
with them like that am I wrong like if
you see someone that is handsome and
looks like he's in your age bracket yeah
there's always like a weird tension yeah
like why at the airport though totally I
don't know but we were in line and there
was there was the the tension was
building he was not looking at me by the
way so your tension my not his not his
just mine so I decide screw it he's like
about to he's in line he's about to go
to the stand so he he would have been
gone it would have been a missed
opportunity I'm like okay let me say
something and I said hey you go to USC
and he says no and I go oh and then he
goes I just work with the the team and I
go okay I thought you were a Trojan with
all your gear and he goes no bye and he
walks away and I was like I'm not going
to lie it was one of the saddest moments
I've seen he gave me nothing and then
the guy in front of us cuz there was a
guy in between this like older man what
did he say to you or I think he was like
damn that's
hard and he's like this older guy and he
has all his like Gucci gear on he goes
damn that's tough
and then I told her I said look I tried
to tell her I try and he goes listen I
respect she shot her shot but damn damn
so I walked to the counter with my tail
between my legs I never saw him again
what happened to noboy November I never
I I said no alcohol November it's you
also said no boy no glute November ah
how's that working for you well
obviously well cuz definitely I'm a
repellent at this point with all my
cystic acne
[Music]
I'm just [__] on myself today yeah
[__] on me [__] on me about something
okay roast me roast me oh I actually
want to ask you this cinee said that her
ex reached out and she was going to
maybe see him in LA but you end up not
doing that
why it was a conundrum big word of the
day it was a conundrum
conundrum because part of me has this
false sense
of I don't even know how to describe it
like I I truly believe in my delusional
state that you can be friends with your
exes and I'm starting to realize as I
get older that's just not feasible
that's not really a thing unless you
guys ended on total agreement and it was
perfectly platonic then there's just no
way it's what's the point I also think
once you've been intimate with someone
there's no backpedaling as to like how
they viewed you before like the
relationship will never be the same yeah
well I yeah obviously people have their
own opinions about this and they go yeah
I can be friends my if you can show me
the way show me the
Carfax
Sophia anyway so I had this big debate
in my head because he' reached out for
my birthday in June and it was just his
birthday so I thought okay I'm going to
text him as well cuz he made the first
White Flag and so I did and we were
talking it was so nice the conversation
was super platonic and sweet you guys
are on a amicable note so totally it's
good so I was like you know what why not
see him when I'm in La like just to grab
coffee or
dinner but then I also was start people
were asking what are you going to gain
out of this conversation like do you
need closure do you want to truly see
how he's doing do you think it'll make
you feel better feel worse and I was
like holy [__] I actually don't need
anything from this person so why would I
put my myself through this emotional
battle to potentially feel like oh maybe
I do still like him or maybe I hate him
more same for him too you might have
been doing him a favor as well because
it's also if you don't think you're
going to see something coming from that
then don't put him in the position of
thinking that there is totally you know
yeah I think it was a smart idea thank
you like I do I do like your guys's um
friendship is that you guys have but I
do think that some things need to just
lie as they are and not you know push sh
I know I know there's no reason to um
another thing we did in La though I have
to share cuz I'm just so nervous about
it I'm not going to lie we went to our
Production Studio for our TV show and we
sat in the room for what 10 hours
editing the family Stallone from episode
one to episode
10 I'm not going to lie I look freaking
boy obsessed crazy in this next season
yeah I thought you were going to say
something to deny
that you do I look insane yeah you do
but it's okay I kissed someone on camera
no you look Fun by the way compared to
last season you look way I'll be honest
you didn't showcase your personality
that much yeah but personality no it's
it's not it's you are you're okay in
your defense that was just kind of the
emo of your story line was like okay
we're going to have sinee dating dating
a l and then it just ended up being that
way I mean I date someone at the end but
it's more so you get to Showcase like
your humor like you look funny in it all
the guys look kind of crazy in it you
don't look crazy you look a little boy
obsessed but you don't look crazy I
understand dating when you're 25 is
totally normal and if it was just
playing out as it did on camera I would
feel fine yeah but it's what they did
with the editing that really kills me so
funny they have me in slowmo biting my
lip in slow-mo playing this romantic
music as I'm do like it's so literally
you guys it's so funny like when you see
the Tactical training of her wrestling
one of the guys that was a Navy SEAL I'm
literally wrestling a Navy SEAL and he
has me pinned down on the ground like
this and cinee bites her
lip he's trying to teach us how to
combat someone and I'm you see me on the
side I'm knocking this like 68 man to
the grow cuz you're supposed to f come
over this Jean literally sits there she
no they have they zoom in on my face
they put this hazy filter on it to make
it look romantic they put me in slow-mo
they play Let's Get It On by Marvin Gay
and then they see me slow-mo biting my
lip as this guy has me pinned
down I mean
yeah I'm could to like who's going to me
after that you look awesome Sophia I so
funny no you don't look insane you look
awesome um I I mean look I'm like the
one on the side going I don't want to
date anyone I look like Mr Grump over
here like no boys for me still it's just
no it's you look fun you look fun it's G
to be funny you guys are going to love
it I love it she definitely loves it
it's good the the the guy choices aren a
little questionable wait speaking of
guys so
the The Haunted House date that I went
on yeah he was giving me [__] that I'm
not spontaneous enough and that I don't
travel more and that I don't do this
more and I'm too in my head about
everything and I should just go and live
life and not think and you know talk it
over with myself after I've done it all
this [__] right so I got hyped up I
got hyped up and I was like you know
what you're right so I booked a trip to
London alone yeah but you know for one
one was for work but then you ended up
extending it what am I gonna like what
am I going to do alone in London well
your original plan was to go with with
someone yeah but that's also crazy and
now you're like you don't want to do
that so now I don't know what you're
doing in London alone crazy will you
come with me please please we can go to
magic mic show like we did last time
please I mean look everyone's probably
like you're complaining about going to
London no look I love London but I also
just want to be in the heat I don't want
to be in the cold again I literally just
am leaving the cold to go back into cold
what am I going to do
alone you then just don't stay there
that long come back I already know you
you're going to come back early damn it
booking it back okay so cinee and I were
thinking about how we wanted to map out
this chaotic silly episode silly goofy
episode and of course you say goopy
goofy you said
goopy I had a speech delay well I was 12
so doesn't count no so we were thinking
silly goofy episode and we are thinking
what we wanted to talk about and we
thought it'd be fun to bring back our OG
segments and so is going to have a
bedtime story unless are you serious no
cuz I was going to do um listener
question okay I'm going to start this
again
sorry so cinee and I were talking about
how we wanted to plan this silly episode
that we're currently doing and we
thought it'd be fun to bring back OG
segments and so I'm bringing in a
conspiracy theory is and Stine's going
to do some listener questions I know she
put it on her story so I don't even know
what the questions are she doesn't know
what the conspiracy is but I can kind of
start cuz mine are pretty quick and mine
are less conspiracy but
more theories if that makes sense lay it
on me sister okay I have two I have two
okay ready conspiracy
theory okay so speaking of Harry Potter
oh you know we've been in this trend you
know when they light up their wand it's
um lumos yeah right and then to turn off
it's noox yes okay watch this ready
she's pulling out her
phone
lumos what
sirios wait
nox it's not working but it says let me
know if you want to turn it off but so
basically what I just did was if you
tell Siri lumos it turns on your camera
light your camera
flashlight is that kind of cool wait but
that's not a conspiracy theory no I said
they were theories oh that's not even
that's that's just that's an iPhone hack
yeah I knew it you know what this is why
I never let you pick the theories
out I couldn't find any are you kidding
me okay I was going to do one for
Christmas and and the conspiracy was
that the Grinch That Stole Christmas The
Grinch wanted to kill all the characters
in hooville and I thought that was
thought that was too
dark that would have been better than
giving me an Apple
hack Sophia okay I have another one now
this is this is just more this is not
this is now just a theory okay so now
this is totally off this is this
episode's So Random okay so did you know
the side that you sleep on in your bed
is tells a lot about your personality
lay it on me okay so psychologist say
what side do the bed you sleep on I
sleep on the right s on my yeah my right
side okay so psychologists say that the
left side are people who are hardworking
happy and self assured they I sleep on
the left side wait I'm not done they
also prefer old music drama movies and
beer people on the left side and they
say that people on the right side are
more grounded they're more analytical
and logical and you may also enjoy rock
music action movies and wine what what
if you sleep on both because I toss in
turn then yeah I can see a mixture
between the two of you I'm on the right
I'm for sure that one okay that's
interesting isn't it interesting that's
all I
have you had one
job you had one job
lumos this
[__] I'll tell you a theory I think
we've said it on the show before but
just to sort of make up for your failed
job here um the theory is that what if
oxygen is actually poisonous we already
did this on our other episode I'm
telling Chris oh thank you what if
oxygen is actually poisonous and it
takes about 75 to 100 years to kill us I
guess we'll never know I guess will'll
never know that's all we need to know
should we do some listener questions
yeah please yeah please I also wrote
down this is what I wrote down this is
my favorite episode we shot um I wrote
down is our Webkins dead I think so or
is our Club Penguin dead they're
probably starving can you imagine how
hungry our Webkins are right now oh
speaking of starvation there's also a
Harry Potter theory that he ucin the
entire thing because he's stuck under
his uh staircase starving and that when
he gets taken to Hogwarts that he's
dragged by like crazy people and he's
just imagining the whole thing or what
if Hogwarts is heaven or maybe he
died well that's not heaven he gets
killed why is there sad music playing
outside oh okay this person actually
wrote a good question okay she said how
can I start to feel comfortable going to
the gym alone as a
beginner that's tough cuz I still get
uncomfortable going to the gym sometimes
I'm always uncomfortable what's helped
me though is when I just listen to music
I feel like I'm
not I'm still to in my head about who's
around or do is my form bad or whatever
so I actually listen to either an
audiobook or a podcast there's something
about listening to other people speak
that distracts you because you're
focusing on that I also think that two
things have helped me a lot with getting
over gym anxiety which is so funny
because I never really had that until I
moved here I get kind of not nervous but
I just to get a little overwhelmed with
so many people in there is that I wear
whatever makes me super comfortable I'll
lit wear sweatpants to the gym and a
tank top and that will make me feel
comfortable and I get two weights and I
stand in the corner and I just do what I
need to do like I don't sometimes use
all the racks like some of times those
machines are just too much and a guy
like standing behind you just inine
that's the worst when someone's like uh
Taps you on the shoulder yo how many
sets you got left get the hell out of my
face you know it's funny I don't get
that at all you do a lot how about when
I'm done sir thank you yeah but that's
what I think that's a good suggestion is
listening to something that distracts
you you know getting two weights moving
to a corner that you feel like you know
and wearing your comfortable clothes yes
yeah put on a little makeup too it
always makes me comfortable this person
said can you give dating advice for
25-year-old girls who are starting
online like hinge Etc you're you're you
should answer this one I think and
people won't agree but everyone has
somewhat of a type that they like M and
I know it's so silly to have to pay for
extra things on a dating app but hinge
for example if it means me spending four
more dollars to specifically see the
only only the guys that I like that
helps a lot um I would say advice don't
give any online guy your weekends so do
not say yes to a Friday or Saturday date
give them only weekdays don't go to
dinner maybe just drink so if you hate
it you can leave after the first one and
uh yeah it sucks honestly it sucks and
the weirdest part about online dating is
I start to get in my own head about it
and I start to feel discouraged like if
I don't get if this guy didn't match me
back or he just ghosted me and I'm like
wait he doesn't like me or yeah well you
know what's funny speaking of online
dating I just was talking to one of my
girlfriends from college and we haven't
talked in a long time and she has a new
boyfriend now and I was like where did
you meet him they I think they're going
to get married and she was telling him
the moment I met him I knew the like
ground Shook and I just felt it and you
just will know when you know right and
I'm like great that's awesome and I go
where did you meet him and she said
hinge and I it does work and so she said
I said oh why hinge like she's she's
like me where she kind of overthinks
things and she's normally someone that
is traditional and likes to meet someone
in person organically and I said what
made you want to go on hinge and she
goes you know I got to the point where
I've talked enough people that they said
they met someone on hinge and she said
she went into it just not overthinking
it not analyzing every single guy so
intensely of like who said yes who said
no and it just worked like it just you
just have to kind of go into it thinking
like it could work it could not work all
you're doing is trying and so is
everyone else and sometimes you just get
really lucky and so that's what I you
know before the beginning of the episode
I said you know shoot your shot I went
up to that random not USC USC player
and I know it sounds funny but I do
think that the energy you put out there
and the opportunities that you gave
yourself is just going to give it a
greater chance to find the person and so
I think it's smart to do it love that
this person said should I block and
unfollow my ex on IG it bothers me that
I can't be updated with my
life oh yes absolutely okay well let me
explain this because I kind of I went
through a breakup recently where sustain
actually follows her ex the whole time
difference is I have them all muted yeah
for me personally I don't know if you're
like this lady but um lady I am someone
that has a really bad habit of checking
in all the time like I I wish I could
tell myself to not check to not look to
see who they're following who they're
what they're liking it's just it's it's
a part of me like I'm curious to a fault
and so for me and this was and I I don't
know how he felt about it but but for me
and I didn't this was nothing against
him at all I knew for myself for to heal
and grow and move on is I had to just
unfollow him and then remove him as a
follower because he thankfully he's
private so he just I just was able to
like not look at his stuff because he's
private but I muted his friends I
unfollowed him he I removed him as a
follower and honestly and this also
sounds kind of extreme I deleted every
single photo and some people aren't like
that but I swear to you out of sight out
of mind in this generation it is so hard
to move on because you are constantly
being reminded reminded of the good
times the photos the memories I mean
your phone pops up it goes three years
ago today you were in the Bahamas with
your boyfriend and you're like oh God
how do I move on I look so happy there
and sometimes you forget the reasons why
you got to this point and why you know
life turned out the way it did and I
think that the best thing for you or for
me and this this is just personal is
that out of sight out of mind do
everything that you can do to focus on
yourself and if that means removing the
reminders which is for me CU I'm a very
nostalgic person I will go back on every
memory every text every photo all the
time then do that and I know it sounds
tough and it's hard and it feels like
you're you know it's like a death when
you delete these it was tough for me I
just want to say unfollowing and
removing him andot was horrible that
makes it real like yeah it was not easy
I was crying was ex the worst but I
don't have the constant reminder every
single
day there which is also really really
relieving to me that when I go on my
phone I'm nothing is going to pop up you
know 100% someone said what do you do if
your best friend is in a toxic
relationship
oh I know I can answer this a little bit
but I know you probably could too I
think your friends have been in this
situation more than mine I'll just say
this because I think this is so tough to
confront or discuss because you know on
one hand you're looking out for your
best friend's interest but the other
hand you have to also let your friend do
what she feels is right for herself and
so all I recommend is this I think that
you completely have the right to discuss
it with your girlfriend and just say
your concerns and do a from a very very
loving place please be sensitive to it
because I can tell you right now there's
probably nothing worse than hearing your
friends disapprove of someone that you
love and you know immediately that
person is going to shut off be deterred
shut you out which is the last thing you
want to do because they think that you
are always going to be uncomfortable
around your boyfriend I think if you
come in asking questions seeing how
she's doing and really getting to the
root of of then why you're asking these
questions and not accusing but just
coming in very very
delicately then you let her decide
because I think it's more about planning
the seed and just letting your friend
know that you're seeing something you're
hearing
something and that's all you can really
do because I'll tell you at the end of
the day you know everyone has to do what
they got to do and I'm not saying that
this to if it depends on the toxic
relationship if it's if it's something
to an extreme of abuse like I I don't
know to confront that I'm talking about
something a little bit less than that
maybe you just don't approve of her
boyfriend maybe he just doesn't treat
her that well um so I'm talking about
that level not not the extreme level I I
have absolutely no um like to stand on
answering that question because I
wouldn't know what to do but I think
that you then after if she ends up
staying with him you have to support her
and you have to love her and you have to
just be there for her and I just think
that it it's so tough because you will
lose her if you keep bringing it up and
keep shutting her out she definitely
knows she she almost needs to figure it
out for herself you can only give advice
so much exactly before you start to like
you said push someone away and that's
that's my recommendation it's a tough
place I've been there before but I do
believe at the end of the day you have
to you have to be so so so so sensitive
to that person's feelings as well
because it's really easy to you know
you're not in their relationship so
you're just an outsider seeing what
you're seeing and so you have to
understand like she has all these things
and memories with him that you don't so
you know think about if you she was in
your shoes if it was the same thing okay
we'll end on this question because I
really like it tips for self-care when
you are in a mental rut what do you do
to stay well especially in the colder
months you can answer this one I feel
like I'm in a mental rut every day and
what I've found that's helped me through
therapy is I need to I'm one of those
people where if I don't have a schedule
for myself even if it doesn't involve
work then I'll
feel like in I want to stay in bed and
I'll feel in a hole so having a
checklist has really helped me um in
terms of the colder months that's going
to be difficult because you can't really
leave but something I'll Do For example
like today I have my checklist the
podcast and then all the errands that I
need to run and then you just have to
try to make yourself busy getting out of
a mental rat is having distraction and
not distraction as in partying going out
drinking it's having a which the scene
said in a routine because I think that
the last month I've been in a little bit
of a mental rut I think that like with
my skin flaring up and things like that
I've been feeling a little insecure
about it need routine and so I've
decided to have a set routine I'm like
okay I'm going to not drink I'm going to
eat anti-inflammatory foods I'm going to
meditate every single morning I'm going
to go for walks every day I'm going to
work out for 30 minutes if I can it's
just having involving new things into
your life that give you a little bit of
energy it's the newness you need newness
and it does and it has to be healthy
newness it can't be a new man it can't
be a new I mean maybe if it's a healthy
new man but like you have to focus on
healing yourself first I know it sounds
you know no it's true you actually have
to try different things to see what
makes you feel good to get yourself out
of your own head for example I started
saying okay every single morning I'm
going to wake up I'm not going to look
at my phone and I'm going to read 20
pages so that's something I never did I
introduced it and I really like part of
my routine and then I get up and then I
give myself some Praise In The Mirror
cuz that's very important and then I go
design something then I was like okay
I'm going to work out for 30 minutes I'm
going to run so just giving yourself
tasks it makes you almost feel like
fulfilled like you're doing something I
think you have to find something you're
excited about like sinee loves design
she's never you know pursued it before
now she's like I'm going to just do it
every day and that makes me feel good
I'm going to start knitting and she want
okay she wants to start knitting you
want you want some gloves no no how
about a headband yeah I'll make you a
knitting headband like one of those cute
ones I can wear 100% thanks um we'll end
on this question why Sophia is so hot
someone wants to know why am I so hot
you know I think it's my I think it's my
personality I think it comes from the
inside out and then I'm so sorry for
this episode I am so sorry about it no I
I'm really sorry um we we really love
you guys let's see if we release it
let's see if we release it I think we
should all right for shits and Googles
all right we love exposing oursel and we
love you guys thank you so much for
listening to this very confusing episode
of the unwax podcast I hope your Monday
has some laughs and you know you can
Tuesday come out on Tuesdays yep there
we go yep um we're going to keep doing
unsolicited advice so make sure you
leave your question in the ratings and
review section under our Apple podcast
page subscribe to our YouTube give us
five stars stop giving us one star and
saying we love you yeah what the heck is
nice you're lot you're giving us bad
rankings five if you like us give us
five if you have a complaint DM us don't
give us one please honestly the way
you're yelling at them I'd give us one
star too that was a little scary I'm
just passionate she needs some coffee we
love you guys we'll see you next Tuesday
don't coffee I need bye